Like most things in Unreal,
Unreal has got its own methods for casting
with a lot of inbuilt checks and error catches in place
to help engineers along the way.
Let's take a look at a few of the main types of cast
you're likely to use
during the development of your project.
Firstly, we've got the is a check
that will return a bool
if this class is of a particular type.
In this instance, is this class a fruit?
Useful for if you want to make sure
that we're dealing with the appropriate types
without necessarily needing to access that type.
From there, we've got a normal templated cast
that will convert this object into a pointer
of a templated type if possible.
If this cast fails, a null pointer is returned.
This will call is a before proceeding
to convert the pointer.
Next, we've got the exact cast for the template
and it will convert this object to the templated type
but only if the types match exactly.
Lastly, we've got cast checked
and this will convert the object
into a point of a templated type
but crash if it fails.
It will call is a before proceeding to convert the pointer
but not in a shipping build.
And as a result,
the cast checked is slightly more performant cast
outside of development environments.
This cast can and should be used
to explicitly convey the intention of the code.
For example, the behavior tree component
is married to the AI controller.
So a cast checked is perfect
for when retrieving the owner.
Nothing else should be owning the behavior tree
aside from the AI controller.
Of course, more standardized types of cast
such as static, reinterpret and C style
are all still available
but 99% of the casts are typically done
using Unreal's casting system.